hello everyone this is sean taylor field
application scientist manager for jen
script in north america
with the onset of a new surge of
covit-19
infection globally in the latter part of
2020
and new cases being uncovered of people
who were infected and recovered
that are becoming infected again with
sars cov2
the importance of measuring neutralizing
antibodies
in these individuals and also for
vaccinated individuals
over time using a high throughput and
cost effective approach
has become important for us to be able
to track
how long those antibodies persist
in these individuals to assure
protection
over a longer period of time
so a number of topics to go over in this
talk
but i promise it will be painless and
easy to understand
i'll start with the virus structure then
the mechanism of infection for sars cove
ii the currently available tests and the
importance of
timing of sampling to assure accuracy in
test results
then we'll get into the neutralizing
protective antibodies
and the associated tests that are
available currently available for
using to assess those levels in
individuals
then we'll discuss a brand new test
that's out there
called the c-pass sars cove 2
neutralizing antibody kit
abbreviated c-pass svnt
we'll compare the c-pass sdn t-test
with traditional igg igm serology tests
directly
also comparing c-pass svnt with live
cell neutralization assays
and finally a semi-quantitative approach
to directly compare neutralizing
antibody titers
over time which is important as i
mentioned
for vaccination and for people who have
been infected
and recovered from disease to assess how
long those protective neutralizing
antibodies can persist
and finally as flu season approaches
obviously cross reactivity for any test
is important and we'll go through that
as well
what we have here is a cartoon image of
the virus
and we have the spike glycoprotein
in red and yellow here i've colored the
yellow portion
of the spike protein as the receptor
binding domain so this
portion of the spike protein this is all
the same protein that's red and yellow
but this portion is what binds to the
host cell so this
this image here this surface here would
be the host cell
and this blue patch here
would be what's called the ace2 receptor
so
the ace2 receptor at the surface of the
host cell
that this could be in the lining of the
lungs as an example
permits the virus to bind by its spike
protein in the receptor binding domain
so you see these two are bound here
and then the virus can enter and inject
its rna into the cell to permit the
virus to replicate
so this is the way the virus is able to
enter and transmit rna to be able to
replicate
so if we look at the comparison between
a nucleic acid test in a serology test
the nucleic acid test is a very highly
sensitive test
for early detection and this is because
it's detecting the rna while the virus
is still propagating in the body
so it's but it is dependent on sampling
so
i've seen a lot of these nucleic acid
tests come back
negative simply because the sample
wasn't taken appropriately and the rna
degraded
in the sample and if you have degraded
rna then again the test will come back
negative and that will be a false
negative that patient was
positive but because the sample wasn't
handled properly
it could come back negative so
it's very important that sampling is
done correctly and at the
and that the sample is stored in the
correct buffer to assure
that that that the rna is preserved
correctly
now of course if this is done properly
this will
dramatically reduce the disease period
which is the period
over which an individual doesn't know
that they're infected right where they
can go around and infect other
individuals
so the sooner the individual knows that
they're infected the sooner they can
quarantine
and isolate themselves from other people
to prevent further infection
serology tests on the other hand are
detecting the antibodies
post infection so of course the
antibodies
only come about after the immune
response is launched this is typically a
week to 10 days
after infection and
but the antibody test could be positive
when the nucleic task
when the nucleic acid test is negative
and that's because
the patient has already
launched an immune response defeated the
virus and all that's left
is the antibodies as opposed to the rna
so
again this permits asymptomatic
individuals to confirm post-infection
and it also permits contact tracing so
for individuals who didn't know they
were infected they can then go back
and contact trace all the people they
came in contact with
to to assure that those people remain
isolated
so these are complementary tests
as i mentioned before in the previous
slide if
the molecular test comes back negative
it's always a good idea to perform a
serology test
to just assure that that individual
hasn't already been infected
and has launched an immune response
so now let's get into neutralizing
antibodies
so neutralizing antibodies are the
antibodies
that are part of the immune response
that are launched during the immune
response
that can block the ability of the virus
to bind to the ac2 receptors so these
antibodies
will specifically bind typically
to the spike protein and typically
even very specifically to the receptor
binding domain right at the tip
of the spike protein to block the virus
from binding to the h2 receptors so here
we have
the lipid bilayer of a cell with the h2
receptor
in pink and the virus is binding here
because there's no neutralizing
antibodies which which permits the virus
to bind and then
the rna will be injected in the cell and
the and the virus will replicate
however if a patient has already been
infected they've launched an immune
response
typically they'll generate neutralizing
antibodies which will bind
and block the ability of the virus to
bind to the ac2 receptor and therefore
the virus can't replicate so
you are protected from the propagation
of enviro of the virus
and infection so the two most common
pre-existing neutralizing antibody tests
are the virus neutralization test
abbreviated vnt
and the pseudovirus based virus
neutralization test abbreviated pvnt
both of these tests require working with
a virus either the live stars cove two
virus in the case of vnt
or a pseudovirus which is a lentivirus
typically
that's expressing just the spike protein
of sars cove ii
so this would be an innocuous virus
in the case of the vnt because you're
working with live virus
it requires a bcl3 level containment
facility
which means protective equipment
skilled technicians who work in this
kind of
environment with highly dangerous
biomaterial and
expensive time-consuming laborious
process
in the case of the pvnt assay
where you're working with an innocuous
lentivirus that's just expressing
the the spike protein of sars cove 2
this is a safer way of working with a
live virus
and therefore doesn't require a bcl2 lab
because there's no risk of infection
but it still requires working with live
cells
and live lentivirus which is still
time consuming and laborious
so in both cases you have the virus
whether it be a live virus or lentivirus
incubating with the sample that the
person who's been infected previously
previously with sars cove2 and
if that sample contains neutralizing
antibodies then
those antibodies as we see here will
bind
on the outside of the virus and prevent
the virus from binding to
the ace2 receptor in cells that are
transfected
with that receptor that's illustrated
here in orange
so we can see the neutralizing
antibodies prevented the virus
from binding and therefore we get no
signal
in the case where we don't have
neutralizing antibodies
then the virus can bind to the h2
receptor
as we see here and then we get a signal
now there are there are a number of
these live cell tests in some cases the
signal is a light emitting signal so we
see here luminescence
in other cases it's it's a called a
plaque reducing or foci reducing assay
where where we get more or less plaques
depending
on on how much neutralizing antibodies
are there
in both in all of these cases though
there for both vnt and pvnt
it's a laborious test requiring a lot of
time
and or a biosafety level 3 lab
in a newly invented test we have the
c-pass
sars cove 2 neutralization antibody test
so this is a gen strip
product and this is an innocuous
easy straightforward elisa based assay
now i'll discuss it in in more detail in
the next slide but suffice to say
that because it's an elisa based test in
96
wells it's way higher throughput than
these
than these cell-based assays and it only
requires one to two hours to perform the
test with basic reagents
in a in a biosafety level two lab so
very
easy test to do it's your typical
straightforward
elisa test so how does the c-pass
sars cove2 neutralization antibody test
work what we've done with this test
is we've purified the components the key
components
involved with docking the virus
to the ace2 receptor so we're looking
focusing in just here at the docking
site
and what we've produced is the purified
very tip of the spike protein which is
what's called the receptor binding
domain so the the domain
of the spike protein that locks on to
the ace2 receptor
which is depicted here in brown and
we've conjugated that receptor binding
domain
to horseradish peroxidase which is which
is what we're using
as our signal generating molecule
in this test we've also purified
the cytosolic domain
of the ace2 receptor of the cell which
is depicted here in green
and we've we've coated elisa plates
with the ace2 receptor as you see here
and we've produced a solution
of purified receptor binding domain
conjugated to horseradish peroxidase
so if we have neutralizing antibodies
which are
depicted here in red and then
non-neutralizing antibodies which are
depicted here in blue
let's say from infection we generate
some of each
you'll see that the non-neutralizing
antibodies
they'll bind they could potentially bind
to the receptor binding domain
and we'll also get a binding of
neutralizing antibodies
and it's these neutralizing antibodies
that will block the ability
of the receptor binding domain
to bind to the ac2 receptor if it's
blocked
then we get no signal if only
non-neutralizing antibodies are in
the patient's serum post-infection
then of course the receptor binding
domain can bind to the ac2 receptor
as we see here in a complex it's a very
tight complex so this binding event is
very strong
and will get a signal produced from the
horseradish peroxidase
now this what this whole assay was
invented by the doctor
dr lin phil wang in his lab
the article is is here it was a
pre-print and it's been published now in
nature biotechnology
and this assay is nice because the
protein components permit it to be
species independent and i'll talk about
this in more
detail so this assay has been
commercialized
under the c-pass sars cove 2
neutralizing antibody kit
name for ce and hsa marked products
and as the surrogate virus
neutralization antibody test
for r-u-r-u-o research use only
applications
so just to give a specific example of
how the c-pass
sars co-2 neutralizing antibody test
works
what we do in this test is we start
by mixing the individual sample the
person who was infected and recovered or
vaccinated
from stars cove two
with the purified rbd hrp
complex mixture so we make this mixture
and we incubate this mixture
together for 30 minutes
after a 30-minute incubation in the case
where we're generating neutralizing
and non-neutralizing antibodies you can
see that the neutralizing and
non-neutralizing antibodies
are binding to most of the molecules
there's one molecule here that only has
a non-neutralizing antibody bound and
then after
after a 30 minute incubation we add the
mixture
into the assay plate which contains the
h2 receptor coated to the bottom of the
wells
so in the case of the of the
rbd hrp complexes that are
bound to neutralizing antibodies in red
they can't bind to ace2 receptor this
one molecule that's only bound to a
non-neutralizing antibody
has its receptor binding domain
able to link to the ace2 receptor
so it binds so when we wash the plate
we wash away these three molecules
because
they can't bind they're in solutions
they'll be washed out of the plate
the one molecule that could bound
remains
so this is just to depict the the rbd
and the ace2 receptor so we have one
molecule bound
and then we add tmb and we get a light
yellow color from the hrp that's bound
to the rbd
in the case where there are no
neutralizing antibodies
then all of these non-neutralizing
antibodies
are either binding or in this case not
binding to receptor binding domain
but because these are non-neutralizing
antibodies
all of these receptor binding domains
are now capable
of binding to their respective ace2
receptors as we see here with the arrows
so now all four of these molecules will
bind
and when we wash the plate because it's
a very strong binding interaction
they'll remain bound
and then when we add tmb of course
there's many more hrp molecules now
which are the signal generating
molecules with tmb so we get a darker
yellow color
the more hrp the more yellow the color
so as we have less neutralizing
antibodies
we generate a darker and darker yellow
color
and as we have more neutralizing
antibodies the color is much
lighter here and this can be quantified
so what are the advantages of the c-pass
svnt assay for detecting immunoglobulins
the first major advantage is that
it's immunoglobulin agnostic so this
test permits the ability
of detecting any class of immunoglobulin
whether these neutralizing antibodies
come from
igg iga igm
or any other class of immunoglobulin it
doesn't matter
they'll bind to the receptor binding
domain and block the interaction to as2
receptor
and will be able to measure this in
terms of the tmb
signal so this permits an augmentation
and sensitivity
vis-a-vis other serology tests that are
on the market
most commercial serology tests are very
specific they use a
specific secondary antibody to a
particular immunoglobulin typically igg
or igm
so here we are able
to pan everything this is like a
total neutralizing antibody measurement
which augments sensitivity of this assay
the other advantage is that it's species
independent why is this species
independent because
these are just proteins so if if a cat
or a dog or a mouse or a rat
are infected with sars cove
ii they'll generate antibodies to the
receptor binding domain
and their antibodies will bind
to purified receptor binding domain in
this kit and prevent
prevent binding to h2 receptor so
any species can be used which which
makes this kit
highly applicable for drug or or vaccine
development
right from the early stages of looking
at animal models or even cell-based
assays
because it's species independent so we
can work from
mouse to primates to humans all with the
same
kit the other advantage of using the rbd
is that the rbd is highly immunogenic
it's one of the most
immunogenic components
of the spiked protein and of the virus
itself in terms of immune response
so if a person or an animal
launches an immune response there's a
very very high probability
that they will generate neutralizing
antibodies to the receptor binding
domain so this was chosen very
specifically
as a consequence of this so that we
would be able to measure the response
very well
second advantage is that the rbd is in
solution it's not coated on the surface
of the plate and in many of the serology
tests that are out there
the antigen which is what rbd is in this
case it's the antigen to these
immunoglobulins
the antigen is bound to the surface of
the plate in many serology tests
so serology tests use either rbd bound
to the surface or the full
s1 domain of spike glycoprotein or
nucleocapsid protein
bound to the bottom of a plate and when
you have
those proteins bound immobilized on the
surface of a plate and it's typically by
a hydrophobic interaction
you can actually cause conformational
changes in those molecules which can
lead
to antigenic sites
becoming available that would not
otherwise be available
in the native state molecule which can
cause
other immunoglobulins to bound at to
bind and therefore
call cause false positive results and
and this is this is seen a lot in these
types of serology tests where you get
false positives
and this is typically because of this
conformational aspect
of being bound to the surface of a plate
in the case of
of this test the rbd hrp
is in solution it's provided in the
kitten solution so it's in a near native
conformation which
forces the immunoglobulins that bind to
rbd
to be very specifically bind to the
near native antigenic sites that would
be
on the virus itself which
augments the specificity so
we increase specificity we reduce the
false positive rate
in this assay and because it's
immunoglobulin agnostic we've increased
the sensitivity so this assay
actually in comparison to other
traditional serology tests out there
is more sensitive and more specific and
i'll show some data in
in the next slides the other final
advantage of this test obviously is that
it's a dual detection and functional
assay
so this test not only has
greater sensitivity and specificity than
traditional serology tests
but it also tells you something about
the function of the antibodies
in their ability to block the binding
of rbd to the ac2 receptor
defining these antibodies as
neutralizing
so this is another great advantage of
this test because
neutralizing antibodies are in fact what
we're really interested in
when it comes to infection because those
are the protective antibodies
that prevent us from having the virus
propagating in our cells
and finally it's very fast this test is
a 96 well plate-based assay
that takes about an hour a little over
an hour
to to perform for 96 wells and it's can
anik and it can be automated
for for mass testing
[Music]
so here's some data from a particular
lab
in a toast laboratories where they
compared
a number of different traditional
serology tests that are out there
using either igg or ig iga
or igm and compared
the the identical samples they had 84
negative samples and 10 positive samples
with the c-pass svnt test that i just
explained
and as we see here
all these tests gave variable levels of
sensitivity and specificity
where c-pass was 100 in terms of both
sensitivity and specificity for these
for delineating between the negative and
positive samples
but even more importantly uh the
positive and negative predictive value
and accuracy were
widely different between these assays
as you can see here versus the c-pass
test
so this is data from an independent lab
that was testing the kit
that wanted to compare and assess
to pick a kit that gave them the best
results and c-pass definitely showed
this
[Music]
in another study that we performed we
looked at
again a number of different kits so this
was a kit
that used an rbd coated plate this was a
kit that you
used spike s1 coated plates and
nucleocapsid coated plates
and again what we see here is
um in the case of the rbd coated plate
for the 40 um 45 presumed positive
samples
it called 43 of them positive and two of
them negative
but in the case of the 23 presumed
negative samples and when i say presumed
negative these were pre-pandemic samples
they
should be negative samples it called
three of them positive which which is a
very high false positive rate
in the case of the spike s1 coated plate
it called many of the positive of the 45
positive samples it called many of them
negative so a lot of false negatives
here
in the case of the nucleocapsid coated
plate
again it called many of the 45 positive
samples
negative 17 if we go to the c-pass
test it was it was better than all three
of the other tests
in terms of it called most of the
samples
positive that were positive 39 of the
samples were called positive
and all of the pre-pandemic samples were
clearly called negative
interestingly the six false
negative samples from the c-pass test
the six samples of the 45 that were
called negative here
were also called negative in the
nucleocapsid test and in
the s1 test where
the specificity of those tests were very
good
so our suspicion is that these six
samples were either samples that didn't
zero convert
or they were samples that were called
falsely positive by qpcr so these were
presumed positive by qpcr
and there are some there is some
controversy out there
with qpcr testing in terms of uh
what the cutoff is used to us to call
a sample positive or negative and
because these six samples
in red were the same six samples that
were negative in these other two tests
where it's not certain that these
samples were in fact
truly positive and if that's the case
then again c-pass called these samples
perfectly because these samples
if in fact were truly negative were
actually called negative
by the c pass test
in the second study where we looked at
41 presumed positive samples and 27
pre-pandemic samples in the case of the
rbd coated plate
it called in this in this particular
study it called all of them
all the pre-pandemic samples negative
and there was one false
negative for the positive samples for
the nucleocapsid plate
again it called many samples negative as
it did in study one
and for the c-pass test again it only
called one sample falsely
negative and all the pre-pandemic
samples were called
properly called negative so again a very
good test
corroborating the one false negative
sample was again in common with all
these tests so again we
we're pretty sure that this negative
sample either didn't serial convert
or likely more likely it was called
falsely positive by qpcr
but taking all that data into account
from these two studies
and just using the qpcr data so we
didn't we didn't
we didn't uh we we just judged
everything by by the qpcr
presumed positive data in in terms of
sensitivity and specificity uh c-pass
was
was excellent and in terms of accuracy
positive predictive value and negative
predictive value c-pass
greatly surpassed all the other tests
that were out there and this the the
data in this table is the combined data
from study one and study two
so very very nice results uh
corroborating the data
that in a toast got from their study
actually
now we also compared um so
so basically what what these results
justify
is the use of c-pass
just in delineating between positive and
negative
samples versus other commercially
available
serology tests that are out there that
just use igg or igm
the c-pass test clearly gives
superior more accurate results than
those other tests
but now let's move to looking how c-pass
compares with
traditional neutralization tests so here
we compared c-pass
to live cell
neutralization tests that use live virus
so this
these would be like the gold standard
test
so using c-pass for the 66 samples we
tested
we delineated 40 as being negative
and 26 samples as being positive
when we look at prnt there are a variety
of sense of sensitivity settings that
you can use in prnt
to to that that cause the results to
change so if we look at
fifty percent plaque reduction seventy
five percent plaque production
or ninety percent plaque reduction the
data change so at 50 percent
two of the uh samples
were falsely called positive and then at
75
and 90 neutralization the data were very
similar to the c-pass test there was
only
one sample in red that was called
positive in the plaque reducing test
that was called negative in the c-pass
test
if we go to foci-reducing neutralization
tests
again what we see here with those
samples
is the data changes dramatically when
you change the sensitivity settings
with foci tests so at 90 percent
neutralization many of the samples of
the 45
presumed positive samples were called
negative 22 of them almost 50 50.
when we when we augment the sensitivity
to 75
reduction in foci then we get very
similar data
to the c-pass test in this case there
was one extra negative sample
called negative but the six samples that
were called negative
in the foci tests were also called
negative so these are the red samples
these
these red samples were the identical
samples that were called negative
at 75 percent reduction in foci
if we go to only 50
reduction in foci it calls all the
samples positive
so again what we what
what we think here is that
the c-pass test can actually be used to
help calibrate some of these live cell
tests
um where by using c-pass
we know that at 75 reduction in foci
the results are accurate here so it's
another advantage of the c-pass assay
actually
so very nice data corroborating
uh live cell tests with c-pass
and a message of caution as well with
these live cell tests
that you have to be very careful as to
which
level of sensitivity is used in these
tests because
depending on the level of sensitivity
the data can either change dramatically
as we see here with the foci test
or it can still change significantly
with the
plaque reducing test where two samples
became
positive by using a lower sensitivity
setting
so not only does the c-pass svnt kit
provide superior
and more accurate data for delineating
between
positive and negative sars cove to
infected individuals
versus traditional serology commercial
tests that are out there
it can also substitute or at least
complement live cell neutralization
tests
to determine
whether samples have neutralization
antibodies
but even furthermore this test
can be converted to a semi-quantitative
analysis to assess
neutralization antibody titers between
infected individuals and this is really
important now that we're
in the looking at vaccination where we
want to assess
how the vaccine affects the titers of
neutralizing neutralizing antibodies
generated between individuals and what
cutoff of titer offers
protection versus no protection to the
disease
so here we can finally use this
assay to assess these differences
so the way we do this is with a
neutralizing monoclonal antibody that we
provide separately
with the kit and we produce a standard
curve with that monoclonal neutralizing
antibody
starting from 150 nanograms per ml in a
one in two dilution series and we
generate the absorbance data from the
kit with this
standard curve as well as the percent
inhibition values which are calculated
from
the quantitative instructions that we
that we provide to people who want to
run this assay semi-quantitatively
these data are then plotted on a
graphically in a graphical
representation of od 450 versus percent
inhibition which should generate
a nice linear relationship and this is
to assess
where the od value is that gives a 30
inhibition which is the cutoff between
negative and positive samples so we just
want to know this
to determine what the upper limit of of
of the quantitative range is uh when
we're plotting our actual samples
the lower limit of the quantitative
range is where the
sample dilution curves start to plot
go into their lower plateaus so so for
the this particular plate
the upper limit is 1.2 and the lower
limit is 0.25 so we so what we're
looking for
are data for our individual samples that
fall in this region between 0.25 and 1.2
and the only way to assess to to
reveal points that fall in this range is
to actually
dilute the individual samples as well we
recommend that samples be diluted in a
six point dilution series
starting from a one in ten dilution in
the sample buffer that comes with the
kit
followed by five one and three dilutions
so from one in ten all the way down to
one in twenty four thirty
so for these three samples which
represent a
low neutralization sample
a a medium sample that contains
medium levels of neutralization
antibodies and a sample from from an
individual that had very high
neutralizing antibody titers
these are the these are the way these
curves would look for these types of
samples
and we chose points from these curves
that fall
in the linear quantitative range which
was delineated by these two
dashed lines so we have for the high
sample 0.5 medium 0.6 and
and and an od of 0.7 for the low
and we plot these samples we interpolate
these
od values on the standard curve so the
standard curve is plotted by
the average absorbance of our duplicate
absorbance values at each dilution on
the y-axis
versus log of the concentration on the
x-axis
and we're able to get the titers uh
from those three samples which i've
delineated
in green blue and red for the
low for the low medium and high
neutralization samples
so so now we have tighter values so we
we
calculate from these tighter values just
i've just tabulated them here
so we have the tighter values for high
low medium and low neutralization
and then we multiply those tighter
values by the actual dilution factor
that we used to get a point in the
linear range so remember with the high
tiders we had to dilute the samples a
lot all the way down to 1 in 2430
to be able to get a point in the linear
range so 23.4
nanograms per ml multiplied by 2430
is 56 862
nanograms per mil of antibody
for the medium at 0.6
that we only had to dilute the medium by
one and ninety
so we're multiplying eighteen point
eight by ninety to generate
this value and then for the low
neutralizing titer
at point seven we only diluted that by
one in 10 so
1 16.6 times 10 is only 166.
and then if you wish you can ratio
metrically
assess those values by just dividing the
high values by the lowest values so
so the medium neutralizing
sample was 10 times more than
the low one and the high one was 343
times
than the low one and we've seen this
with actual samples
these kinds of ranges so
what these values mean in terms of a
large sample set
and in terms of can this patient with
the very low titer now be
re-infected are they susceptible to
reinfection
these are all questions that can now
easily be answered
by using the semi-quantitative approach
with
the c-pass svnt kit as depicted here
so just to finish cross reactivity we're
heading into influenza season
so everyone's concerned about
cross-reactivity of all these kits
we've tested the c-pass kit for
cross-reactivity
with all the usual suspects and the only
uh virus that we've assessed that is
cross-reactive with svnt is sars cove
one
which makes this kit highly applicable
even to looking at samples during
influenza season which is now upon us
and finally just species independent
just a little bit of data i know i
explained this
vis-a-vis that we're working with
purified proteins but we have
tested this kit with with mice
uh um also with patient samples
and with rabbits and um there have been
studies using primates as well
so this test is
pan species
the kit has been regulatory approved
by a variety of marks we're still
in review for fda so this is in process
for the eua approval
but for these other marks uh the
approval has been given
[Music]
and if you would like more information
or to learn more about the other
solutions that we provide for sars code
v2 you can visit our website
and we have a variety of protein and
antibody solutions
for folks who are building their own
kits or
you trying to use their own research or
detection techniques
and finally we have a variety of
services available
to help you in the production of your
own assays
if you wish to use these services in
your research
programs so i hope this was informative
and i look forward to any questions that
you might have